Let's talk more about the two sample t-test, since we'll want
to compare two different samples in our class project. There are
a few different versions of the t-test that one might employ
,and they depend on really on what assumptions we make about the
data. So we might want to ask questions such as ,do our
samples have the same size ?,and do they have the same
variance? . Let's discuss a variant of the t-test called Welch's
t-test in more depth. Since it's the most general. It doesn't assume
equal sample size ,or equal variance. In Welch's
t-test ,we compute a t-statistic using following equation.
T equals mu1 minus mu2, divided by the
square root of sigma1 squared over n1. Plus
sigma 2 squared over n2. Where mu I ,is the sample mean for the Ith sample.
Sigma squared I is the sample variance for
the Ith sample. And NI is the sample size
for the Ith sample. We'll also want to estimate the number of degrees
of freedom, nu, using the following equation.
Nu is approximately equal to. Quantity sigma1
squared ,over n1 ,plus sigma2 squared over n2 ,squared over sigma1 of the
4th over n1 squared nu1 ,plus sigma2 to the 4th ,over n2 squared nu2.
Where mu I is equal to mi minus one ,and
this is the degrees of freedom associated with the Ith variance
estimate. If you're unfamiliar with degrees of freedom again it might
be a good idea to brush up on your stats concepts
with the audacity's intro to stats course. A link is
provided in the instructor comments. All right so once we have
these two values, we can estimate the P value. Conceptually, the
P-value is the probability of obtaining the test statistic at least
as extreme as the one that was actually observed
,assuming that the null hypothesis was true. The P
value is not the probability of the null hypothesis
is true given the data. So again, just as a
thought experiment. Say we were testing whether left handed
or right handed baseball players. Were better batters by looking
at their average batting average. If the P value
is .05, this would mean that ,even if there is
no difference between left handed and right handed batters, since
that's our null hypothesis. So, even if this was true,
we would see a value of t ,equal or greater
to the one that we saw 5% of the time.
When performing a statistical test like this, we usually set
some critical value of P. Let's call it P critical.
If P falls below P critical, then we would reject
the null hypothesis. In the two sample case, this is equivalent
to stating that the mean for our two samples
is not equal. Calculating this P value for a
given set of data can be kind of of tedious.
Thankfully, we seldom have to perform this calculation explicitly.